es una de las zonas más ricas de México
Monterrey en Nuevo León goza de un nivel
de vida con el que muchas zonas del país
no podrían ni soñar pero en los últimos
meses una ola de calor y la falta de
lluvias ha provocado la escasez de algo
esencial el agua en la pandemia apenas
como que nos estamos dando un respiro
verdad pero apenas nos estamos dando un
respiro Yo creo que es un respiro muy
corto casi nada y empezó a seguir con
solo unas horas de agua corriente al día
desde hace casi dos meses a muchos como
a María Navarro les toca ir a llenar
cubos de agua de los camiones cisterna y
llevarlos a sus casas ya que casi nadie
puede permitirse comprar tanques para
almacenar el líquido
y le gusta una vez más a terminar la
calle tiene que venir el agua
pero yo me desespero mucho con el agua
el clima árido y las temperaturas de
hasta 38 grados Celsius en la zona en
verano complican el flujo de agua al
igual que las muchas empresas de la zona
que consumen cantidades enormes del
Preciado líquido en esa parte hay que
recordar lo que está determinado en la
ley de aguas nacionales donde en épocas
de crisis o de incertidumbre siempre hay
una prioridad en el consumo humano sobre
las explotaciones industriales y
agrícolas sin embargo eso no está
ocurriendo de manera suficiente motivo
por el que tras negociaciones con las
autoridades locales las fábricas de la
zona han dejado de operar unos días a la
semana para ahorrar agua dejando un
escenario desierto en las afueras de la
localidad